de cette pièce
patrick cohen sur france n comment
définir l'âge des mineurs isolés
étrangers en tout cas pas en regardant
une radio de la main et du poignet deal
réseau éducation sans frontières
l'association a lancé il ya un mois une
pétition qui réclame la suppression de
ces examens osseux pour les jeunes
migrants
cet appel publié dans le monde a
recueilli plus de dix mille signatures
bonjour mathilde denis genre patrick ce
qui est nouveau c'est que parmi les
signataires on trouve de plus en plus de
médecins et le radiologue
oui car ils ont l'impression de se
retrouver en première ligne dans les
faits ils ne sont consultés qu'à l'issue
d'un parcours administratif qui débute
avec la vérification des papiers de ces
jeunes migrants on les interroge sur
leur histoire et ça ne semble pas
crédible le parquet de monde ce fameux
tests osseux pourtant imprécis
katia chaumoître et s'amuser
[Musique]
et
je suis arrivé en france j'étais encore
un enfant
donc parce que la france il part à 10
alors que en arrivant en france qu'on
voit que la principale paradis donc je
me suis trouvé en galère
psychologiquement aussi c'est difficile
à la famille mais moi qui ai beaucoup
j'imagine que la france s'estime bpo
pour gagner facilement de l'argent de
l'enlever de l'argent à la famille mais
alors que c'était pas ça
[Musique]
et
je me suis lancé dans le métier
d'interprète
j'ai fait des récits avec des mineurs et
je vais donc oui à des histoires qui est
qui ressemble à mon histoire
à l'intérieur ça bouge que l'histoire et
des histoires ça touche il sort sa
touche mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire
tu le sais ou pas mais nous sommes déçus
mais moi ce que tu sais déjà
mais les démos des jeux qu'il va parler
de son histoire
ouais et tu va l'écrire ouais et
jusqu'ici pour quoi faire
mais ils sont ici ici et qui sait pas
pourquoi
d'accord alors là c'est un moment
important un ton dans son histoire vous
savez quelle nature de nenê bien puisque
tu es arrivé en france 2 - dix jours
depuis tu es avec nous sur le sénat
enfin tu me parles de ton parcours il
faut que tu ne parles de ta famille
c'est un peu intrusif mais bon c'est
comme ça je suis obligée d'avoir le
maximum d'éléments pour expliquer au
juge pourquoi tu es venu en france et
pourquoi tu as envie d'y rester
alors je sais un peu tendu donc il va
falloir se détendre garçon s'était pas
dans un tribunal ici ou là c'est moi qui
aime aider la socan et ceux qui sont
divulgués
il incarnait à thann et les truies
remercie de me blâmer qui ont doublé
mais est-ce que j'aurais dit avec les
iniquités depuis depuis le départ de sa
soeur eddy curry et les parties juin
d'une organisation dans les montagnes et
du fils départ de sa soeur née comme ça
il a laissé ses parents et son pied
derrière lui sa cause de la violence
qu'elle a quitté son pays
nous ce qu'on fait ce sont des notes
dead à la décision notre boulot c'est
d'aider les magistrats à prendre la
décision de justice la plus juste la
plus proche de la réalité du gène il est
très difficile avec d'accompagner des
jeunes qui sont dans une grande
précarité
il ya un marseille des réseaux
communautaires qui sont bienveillants et
heureusement qu'on les a parce qu'ils
aident ces jeunes dans un temps dans le
temps de l'arrivée
en attendant les procédures et on
travaille avec eux il ya aussi des
réseaux à marseille qui ne sont pas du
tout bienveillant des réseaux
d'exploitation des réseaux de traite
donc on a des jeunes qui sont en risque
de prostitution on a des jeunes qui sont
en exploitation pas en risque mais en
exploitation
d'un certainement de présente si si
fera une évaluation social éducatif
[Musique]
on refait une case ici à lomé le texte
là ok d'accord et on dessine ce qui se
passe si bon qu'on thomas sa jolie c'est
un couteau c'est vrai que c'est ça ton
père comme ça oui je pense pas du tout à
fait mais presque plus dur plus d'un an
elle adore à la fois dans le groupe pro
cee'd altamir qu'est-ce qu'elle allait
la barrière et trois bars et c'était pas
la première fois que j'entre et les
médias ils sont tellement nombreux nids
sont assemblés en a couru on ne plus
rester sur la barre comme avant je
m'appelle ibrahim
j'ai 16 ans je suis né en turquie
je suis arrivé à paris et puis de paris
a marché j'ai trouvé mon frère j'ai pas
des papiers ici je n'arrive même pas
travailler je dois retourner vivre en
turquie mais moi je viens d'arriver
frej qui va s'occuper de moi
le galop
si vous me demandez pourquoi je suis
venu en france c'est parce que ici on
respecte les droits de l'homme et les
droits des enfants
mais les deux hommes
j'ai posé mon
n'est pas égal
mais l'ado sa maman
zerah b2
des mots des veaux de moscou daegu
c'est un cadeau écolo
j'ai 16 ans je viens de l'afghanistan
j'ai perdu mon père dans mon pays je
suis parti avec mon frère au long du
chemin que j'ai perdu aussi mon frère je
monte dans un bateau y avait certains
qui étaient déjà montées encore il y
avait une panique tout le monde courait
dans tous les sens les gens disaient
qu'ils à la police donc il y en avait 12
personnes déjà dans le bateau et le
bateau a démarré et donc moi je suis
resté dans le bateau donc le mon frère
elle n'a pas pu prendre au bateau depuis
cinq ou six mois ou sept mois
il a plus de nouvelles de son frère
[Musique]
voyons
sympa le bras
en tant que mineur donc de moins de 18
ans vous n'avez pas besoin de documents
de titre de séjour pour pouvoir rester
en france dans la loi c'est la loi de la
protection de l'enfance une protection
de l'enfance en danger
vous devez être immédiatement à partir
du moment où vous êtes considéré comme
mineur étranger vous êtes devait être
immédiatement mise à l'abri
pourquoi ça prend du temps c'est
peut-être une des raisons c'est que vous
entends ces mineurs isolés étrangers
on va d'abord évaluer votre situation on
va évaluer si vous êtes vraiment mineure
on va évaluer si vous êtes vraiment
isolé et on va évaluer si vous êtes
vraiment étranger vous êtes en danger
puisque vous êtes isolé
vous êtes mineur en danger donc il ya
aussi des mineurs en danger français
c'est la même loi qui s'applique
a salon disait que j'ai parlé d'une loi
qui est une loi qui normalement dit
voilà qu'une personne avait protégé
qu'ils soient français ou mineurs
étrangers
ça fait deux mois et demi qui attend
toujours en danger dans la rue et
pourquoi ils ont pas un envoi pour être
protégé il veut juste savoir quand est
ce qui peut avoir une place finalement
parce qu'ils pensent que la demande a
été faite par le sénat mais là aucune
nouvelle des filles
il dit que quand il est arrivé ici il
n'avait pas l'extrait de naissance et
thierry lui on dit qu'on ne peut pas de
prendre sans laisserait naissance donc
il a pu joindre ses parents au mali ils
ont envoyé un extrait de naissance mais
malgré les traits de messages le savent
et ne s'est pas occupé de lui finalement
il est allé chercher un avocat et le
juge d'enfants à ordonner un placement
c'est une question de temps quoi il va
être placé le juge a ordonné et affaires
d expertise osseuse pour prouver que
vraiment il a pas dit que là où ils vont
le soir pour manger c'est le croix rouge
ils disent que ils sont mineurs ils
n'ont pas droit d'aller manger là bas
c'est pour les adultes qui sont en
dehors comme ça ceux à eux de venir
manger la batterie sont mûres c'est pas
eu de leur donner à manger
mais après ils ont dit tier 2 ils leur
rendent cas
il pose une autre question me demande
qu'est ce que vous avez dit que ce juge
d'enfants qui évoluent les dossiers
évidemment suffisamment des juges des
enfants pour que ça aille plus vite
il dit sinon demain on va avoir 18 ans
sera terminé du coup y
ça amène on ne peut pas absorber la
totalité des jeunes mineurs isolés qui
arrive sur marseille on a une capacité
d'accueil à 21 jeunes il arrive qu'on
ait 45 jeunes sur le certains
accueillent donc quand on est dans ce
type de configuration le sert bien ça
devient très compliqué de respecter les
délais notamment en termes d'évaluation
nous on ne déplore les délais trop longs
on est des pleurs parce que l'objectif
du sa menace et pas de regarder des
gamins 3 2 sur le service par moments où
je suis en colère parce que je me dis
pour un si petit nombre d'enfants
comment on n'arrive pas à trouver les
solutions
mais je n'ai pas la réponse
[Musique]
je me rappelle comment s'est passé votre
premier jour ont été douchés au sabine
trois mois ça faisait trois mois que tu
t'étais pas laver à l'eau chaude ça fait
du bien aussi sa relève l'auteur
doucement doucement on en train
d'attendre une réponse pourquoi tu
puisses allant de foyer
mais en attendant on marque on est la
réponse est que tu fasses la visite au
foyer et que tu commences ton projet moi
je sais que tu souffres aujourd'hui tu
arrivé ce matin j'étais complètement
antao parce que j'ai pas dormi de la
nuit
j'ai marché toute la nuit tu m'as dit
non plus des barreaux projets ont été
proposés
le jeune là qui est venu tout à l'heure
qui s'assied à côté de toi qui tu as
parlé c'est quelqu'un que tu connais du
squat ou pas non plus tard dans ce cas
comment ya beaucoup de bagages en soute
oui je sais
mais cette personne là tu la connais
elle agit comme ça vient bien voler son
sac et à des fonctions et il faut que je
te pose la question pour que tu me le
dise cette personne là on va reprendre
de volée là dès qu'on arrive parce que
le te propose de voler ça fait combien
de temps que tu te proposes à cette
personne là ça fait combien de temps on
marche pour ya un mois je tourne
éducatrice référent tu sais ce que ça
veut dire ou pas tu sais
est-ce que tu s'approche de sarrebourg
quel est mon rôle a
c'est bon je sais pas quoi
j'aurai un combat à mourir on sait
commentaires pour tu pour te protéger
pour quoi que tu tombes dans le réseau
conseil où c'est notre métier de faire
ça alors faites-nous confiance et dit
non quand les choses elles vont pas
d'accord ok ben on regarde si on va les
images ya un ace et après celle à n
sans s'en sortent et moi alors voilà
bonjour alors c'est une association ici
qui travaille avec des jeunes qui ont
entre 12 et 25 ans alors c'est
entièrement gratuit
c'est entièrement anonyme il se veut
dire quoi anonyme
et pourtant p alors oui anonyme ça veut
dire que on s'en fout de comment tu
t'appelles on s'en fout de dessin pas
que demander des papiers pendant les
initiés ok je sais anonyme c'est
confidentiel confidentiel ce point je
t'avais expliqué hier ça veut dire que
tu peux me dire des chose de ta vie que
tu nous a pas dit à nous elle elle va
garder mes informations ce club parce
que c'est secret exactement c'est
confidentiel ses secrets dans ce lieu là
tu as des psychologues
tu as dû mettre sa
tu veux quoi je vais passer quoi tu veux
voir un psychologue
je veux un mutin alors tu as des
psychologues durée des médecins et tuent
aussi un éducateur un travailleur social
ici oui
la ville le département l'état les
autorités tolèrent que les jeunes de 16
ans passent six mois la rue
c'est révoltant c'est révoltant en tant
que citoyens ont signé ce jeune jules la
ramener chez moi quoi à bouffer
je faire dormir donner une douche puis
après quoi après quoi après quoi si les
autorités ne ne font pas leur boulot
après y'a plus que l'initiative
citoyenne la création d'un réseau
citoyen qui permettent un hébergement
qui permet une prise en charge en
attendant que l'aide sociale à l'enfance
ase son boulot en fait on est tous assez
démunis parce qu'on voit ce drame qui se
passe sous nos yeux et il n'y a pas de
sous pour l'instant on n'a pas de
solution
on comprend pas pourquoi les pourquoi
pourquoi en fait la minorité elle est
pas tant qu'on ne sait pas qui sont
majeurs on considère pas
du coup quand en attendant ils sont
mineurs et dans ces cas là pourquoi
c'est pas la minorité qui passe en
premier au niveau juridique pour pouvoir
accéder à une une mise à l'abri
n'importe quels mineurs français qui est
dehors il va être mis à l'abris
directement quoi là on est dans cette
attente la c'est comme si en fait le
fait qu'il soit étranger
eh ben ça passait devant le fait qu'il
soit mineur enfin moi en fait je
vraiment avant de faire ce travail là je
pensais même pas que ça existait quoi
que c'était possible
enfin deux dans le l'idée générale quoi
un mineur à la rue non en fait n'existe
pas et là on est tous hors la loi en
fait on est tous hors la loi et nous on
est obligés de l'être aussi parce qu'on
les voit les jeunes et qu'on ne les met
pas à l'abri
on peut pas déterminer au regard l'âge
de quelqu'un
et comme bien entendu dans cette
problématique des mineurs isolés
étrangers
la question c'est la minorité il faut
que les autorités décident il a moins ou
plus de 18 ans et donc les autorités se
sont emparés d'un certain nombre de
tests oui c'est le mot qui sont connus
pour n'avoir aucune valeur le test
osseux à une approximation d'une
quinzaine de mois
donc quand on s'annonce comme ayant 17
ans le test osseux peut aller de 15 à 19
fois en 15 à 19 donc le l'autorité
judiciaire peut s'emparer de résultats
en disant voilà où g7
ce résultat là pour moi et les majeures
donc je l'exclus du dispositif de la
zone
on nage en plein délire quoi alors après
il y à l'apparence physique
certains médecins se prêtent au jeu par
exemple de l'observation les poils
pubiens ou développement développement
des seins chez les filles où
développement des organes génitaux
[Musique]
quand lé dinh la pudeur quoi et encore
de toute façon ça reste subjectif il n'y
a aucun élément objectif pour rétablir
l'âge d'une personne
et quand pour ces tests continuent
bonjour au jeu bonjour didier aller
voter c'est l'extrême violence de l'exil
comment montrer ces jeunes et cette
rupture extrêmement violente
le lui gelé senti chez ces jeunes comme
une amputation
donc comment se reconstruire une fois
qu'il manque quelque chose
est-ce que vous avez des questions à me
poser
tu fus tellement tu es à monica studio
marasme et par hermine la veille et quoi
qu'ils cèdent et easy for me wanna
ethnie est peu fait tout ce qu'il peut
mais depuis steve hinds a conclu mon
éducateur sylvain il m'a dit que une
fois que j'aurai mes 18 ans que ce
serait compliqué de rester ici en france
d'avoir un titre de séjour
ah oui moi je parle d'une question sur
votre santé sur le corps sur ce que vous
ressentiez iv message avait pas de
réponse à ces familles qu'il avait pour
ça cela causera skinny - bayonne aof le
contact une forte prévalence santé avec
moi vous dormez bien
sur ma famille ça marche pas bien écouté
dégâts et oui
[Musique]
demont
je m'appelle en moi j'ai 15 ans du parti
ou bhl est bon
alger ce qu'il ya des misères aux blaine
[Musique]
annaba par yale aliens en france
quatre mois
absent à tresques mon challenge foot of
alien jeu uniquement ou la monnaie à
nous d rihanna interne à la toque alors
tu vois qui est en leur triste
j'entrais à marseille 2 6 1
novembre je dors dans un squat il ya
quatre personnes du grand milliards
gracia
[Musique]
du dormeur paula parce qu'il est froid
tous les jours fatigue est toujours géré
à la d
ce n'est pas une humeur et maison n'est
pas la clio monnaie agronomie
je
attends attends tous les jours attends
attends attends mais j'en ai marre
parfois et maman mont palomar de niche
tu vois ce qu'on va pas et les
alcooliques
il faut être amené des fois quand rené
emmener à l'école
gharbi mais moi
30e compilé avec les jeunes
tout
il a fait des propositions omar le
quotidien
et on voir ça des pneus à maria serment
il est arrivé à proposer
ladite a pas d'argent on parle beaucoup
avec moi j'ai fait un procès en plus tôt
dans le monde c'est pas dit qu'on y
trouve un meilleur
un accord
dandy
oui
nous attendrons bad est grand disent
chrétiens et à divers ou quoi
non mais c'est pas
et ce en quoi il peut y accédant journée
aussi aisément crédit
pas d'affaires à l'extérieur
est-ce que c'est mon parcours
d'abord parce qu'ils de taxi ne sais pas
très très moyen là bas
promoteur
après ce qu'ils ont dit
qui dans l'ouest merci je pense pas
qu'ils y soient remis
ah ouais
chaud
don du restaurant carrément
je suis rentrer arthur entre
tu rentres pas bouger d'ici là
j'aime la nuit
pour mafia
maintenant ici il fait très froid et
c'est pas simplement ici et ça semble
plus charge alors du coup
non
un grand coup
adacore
position ambiguë et du coup même le
droff fait des sous dans son sac
une solution
verture attendant les cinq destinations
à pas de géant mais ne le sont c'est
possible mais c'était trop et sacs de
couchage d'accord en attendant si tu
veux rester avec moi
la gare c'est donc tu veux d'abord la
porte
[Musique]
j'appelle jones
nokia n'a qu'un le reste est de tendre
un
oh
à
[Musique]
chafic est un petit louis donc
radioactifs week-end geste comme kiel
one day one day
ok on devait nous revenir à vue ou
certificat you will come on down the way
[Musique]
j'ai appris à dire aux gamins écoute
pour l'instant là ce soir ya pas de
solution pour toi
certainement que demain il y en aura pas
non plus voilà ça c'est plus ou moins
simples canton on connaît pas encore
trop le jeune quand on a des jeunes qui
doivent partir depuis longtemps la omar
ça fait un mois et demi un mois qui
pourrait très bien être en maison
d'enfance ça fait un mois que
l'évaluation de t'envoyer ça fait un
mois que on a demandé la mise à l'oeuvre
en urgence en attendant qu'il ait une
audience avec le juge des enfants
ça fait un mois qu'on dit que il est
dans une qu'il est vraiment en danger
c'est un gamin qui ont mangé et ça fait
trois mois qu'il est là
donc quand je suis revenue de congé et
que je les revues j'ai eu les boules
quoi
ah ouais
le mieux pour
on doit déjà non
c'est dû à lui à diane blais et trois
points a dit liliana au retour d'une
bille l'essentiel ne suis nullement être
humain est le pari manqué foule comme
celle d'al wahda s'entendent bien
autre grand temps de bellecôte il ya un
camion une fille gwadar incana escompte
payet coude sur iis lac dans foot -
sabine et diffuser tout article in the
night and day is because that have the
knitting humphries
[Musique]
je vais voter pour trois heures 59 4
laurent blanc dit en partant ils
ramassent des cartons à la russie
inférieur c'est ça leur couchette et ils
viennent là bas à zéro à minuit et à 3
heures 3 heures 30 et les gardiens leur
réveil vous partez maintenant il est
l'heure de partir donc là le temps avant
le matin il se promène comme samedi pour
attendre le jour qui viennent manger et
si trois fois par semaine et les jours
qui viennent pas mangé par semaine ils
fouillent dans les poubelles du mcdo
dans les restos pour manger où ils font
la manche pour avoir un peu de sous pour
se nourrir et des colosses qui n'est pas
ici doit rester dehors dans la rue et
que à cause de ça il a attrapé une
maladie de peau qu'il est allé voir le
médecin quand même et ça lui a dit voilà
comment tu lui dans quelles conditions
il est dit que les conditions sont très
mauvaises
donc le médecin lui ai dit il faut que
tu prennes une douche il faut que tu
restes dans un endroit propre ce qui
n'est pas le cas donc tu peux pas
prendre douche tous les jours il doit
rester dans des endroits qui sont pas
propres lorsqu'il n'est pas à sanaa
sentiments et ses coffee shop gi est la
star des études médicales décemment
sûrement pour camille de saut quantique
minimum soit sage
come back
mambé moning pendant une partie tous
piquouse est situé au quai
[Musique]
je fais partie c'est mon père qui a
décidé pour moi parce qu' il fallait que
quelqu'un part de la maison pour gagner
de l'argent ailleurs
et aussi nous pas qu'ils avaient eu trop
de problèmes politiques dans notre pays
à chaque fois qu'il ya des gens qui
passent pour donner une protection
oui ça me fait rappeler mon histoire
aussi une peur ça m'arrive de faire des
des récits très difficile dès que je
finisse leur souris si je sors je vais
pas prendre les transports en commun
parfois j'ai essayé marché d'abord un
petit peu de
j'essaie de me protéger un peu
à
je suis arrivé à marseille cet été huit
heures du soir en sortant de la gâche
soit les espagne et je vois une ville
chinoise
j'ai eu peur parce que c'était la nuit
je me suis retrouvé tout seul
[Musique]
m
aïe
[Musique]
à
c'est
[Musique]
environ
à rappeler
femmes et hommes roger coppe hakim
because i do have a new way to go et les
smartbooks pires une bonne glace et
midori because life and a whole
d'éthique à so it was when he died elle
est malaise because either have a new
way to go sera left forme maemo du
gorille hindou ni jeune femme nadia
azoug auto works au fameux rock au
crosstour spain forme ce fait et comme
tout album hold em of déplace débit
faille est à des sauts et trois de
police mal les pattes de police trois
photos des stars état d'esprit owen de
transport mis à l'eau à venir être
gossip tard aux codes son bord du gave
me dise moneda hoebeke sont maudits date
hannut money was the past hello games
ils disent tout et vous je me suis rendu
compte rapidement et il faut aussi la
bordée les jeunes reçus images ne sont
que des garçons
tu reçois une ou deux filles en quelques
années et les jeunes filles
son extrême manger bien sans bien
entendu réseau prostitution réseau d'
esclavage qui menace aussi les jeunes
garçons mais les proies les plus faciles
ce sont les jeunes filles
depuis qu'elle a reçu son invitation à
quitter le territoire elle a
complètement en fait elle s'est
effondrée
puisque c'est tout son projet migratoire
qui s'effondre où elle a du mal à se
lever le matin elle n'arrive plus à
faire ses démarches
les croix n'y croit plus et donc là à sa
demande ses et des mois que tu dises
nature moon
tu as les partis mineurs prise dans un
réseau de 13 institutions prostitution
exactement
voilà c'est ça donc je ne peux expliquer
la différence entre un psychologue et un
médecin on a aussi beaucoup travaillé là
dessus
entre bâle et le spécialiste du corps et
puis nous on était mais je lui ai dit
des fois aussi le corps est bien quand
on n'est pas bien il s'exprime
ça c'est vrai avec tous les gamins mais
ce qui se passe pour ces jeunes en
particulier arrivé à 18 ans vont pas
pouvoir rester en france donc des jeunes
qui s'engagent dans un parcours
d'apprentissage du français de formation
et qui nie tout à coup 18 ans refus de
régularisation et maïmouna
tout un parcours en l'espace d'un hôtel
comment il parle français
elle est arrivée et parlait pas là
maintenant et pas français elle a en
projet s'est investi dans des stages
elle est tout à coup l'un d'eux va avoir
18 ans débutant début juin et on lui dit
1 toute façon y'a aucun espoir pour te
préparer à rentrer chez toi je vais
rentrer chez moi mais mais mais c'est
une envie d'acheter
c'est pas possible on ne fait plus les
dates butoirs se se rapproche et plus
douce et des jeunes qui vont mal qui
sont plein d'angoissé qui n'arrivent
plus à penser à d'autres choses ne
devrait même plus à travailler étudier
j'ai besoin qu'il a retrouvé sa ligne
mais il est un rubicon elle a envie
d'arriver en avril 2015 il as commencé à
être pris en charge par le samanah il
est pris en charge dans dans cette
mecque cela depuis le mois de juillet
[Musique]
bon
j'ai vécu pendant plusieurs années ici
et chaque fois que je viens ici c'est
comme si comme ma maison d'autres
oui c'est un tracé très importante dans
ma vie j'ai appris beaucoup de choses en
écoutant les éducateurs je suis arrivé
en france j'étais encore un enfant
j'ai appris la vie ici
[Musique]
maintenant c'est sa voix pour moi une
classe qu'au même trimestre il faut que
tu te poses des fuites how to go mbm
insisté avicole il n'a tué ok mais c'est
un petit cabanon un système encadré et
l'autre invité fort france inadaptée
sceau des taux de 1000 soit de bois
saint esprit d'études médiator comme des
radios comme un drapeau blanc mais
bientôt comme un saut dans le dire d out
tandis que 850 foyers get money a cup of
life i'm free fight of life le tout
paris foot gay d'armes ubaye food beat
ouganda à sentheim ce thème champoux
soyez guichen pour le christ aux aguets
idem avec des cadres bastille kitt peak
au foyer qui nous habitait
d'équilibriste qui souffre d'un oedème à
capteur because harbin dhabi abu dhabi
foraine aura des situationnistes à nos
torts et septième en cinq minutes les
deux à we had après 113 même foyer même
écoulé à huy ah oui
avant de présenter une fois qu'un jeune
quitte son pays pour venir ici
il reste que j'allais en france même si
on l'envoie dans son pays
il va pas vouloir rester dans ce pays
parce que il à découvrir d'autres mondes
ici même si on les envoie il reviendra
est en tout cas bien le match entre
démont somme mais ça lui par un terrible
un séisme il ya des tonnes d'émissions
ana cata riley noorda aux salariés
aurais tu agis dessous elle a voulu nous
tuer nous attendions à la jeunesse 210
ont peur peur comme dans le régularise
pas leur situation que si on est dans un
foyer à ses 18 ans
si on me demande de partir comme ça
c'est très difficile c'est très
difficile à personnes peuvent se sentir
psychologiquement
maltraité déjà 15 juin qui rentrent dans
leurs foyers il est intégré donc je
pense que à l'âge de 18 ans même si il
faut qu'on ait régularise en fait je
dirais pas ce que ces importantes parce
que ces gens là ces six pour là c'est
l'avenir de la france
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon casque
c'est un échalas après disait bien comme
ça après l'arrêt suivant les cadeaux de
la main du bateau la fourchette
[Musique]
je
tu restes avec lui
à monsieur voulait peut-être vers midi
je devais lui
verra bientôt 17 ans que finama
vous arrivez desquels le pays a dû vous
avez quoi compétition
très rapidement parce que la majorité
des patients que ça ça veut dire qu'il
ya 17 ans et 5 mois chez lui et 17 ans
et 5 mois le temps du placement je sais
même pas si on peut obtenir une
protection pour dire
donc en fait on a deux jeunes
d'afghanistan qui ont débarqué et m'a
chanté hier soir deux frères hier soir
on les a accompagné au commissariat de
noailles qui n'a pas voulu
qui les a renvoyés vers le ca mais n'a
en fait sauf que le service n'a été
fermé donc ils ont passé la nuit dehors
donc il ya le petit frère iman qui a 13
ans et le grand frère qui a 15 ou 16 ans
la concrètement ils sont revenus sont
dans nos locaux mais ils ont dormi
dehors mais on peut pas même les
hébergés à l'hôtel j'en sais rien là il
a 13 ans donc je demain où ça amène à ok
au revoir voilà n'y a pas de solution
damman pas trop si là je fais pas bien
là non mais je vois pas tout le monde
s'en fout tu sais pas
voilà donc ils sont 64 en tout cas
déclaré un enfin recensé quad on campus
et c'est peut-être beaucoup plus
aujourd'hui il ya 64 mineurs isolés
étrangers déclarés auprès du service de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance ase la rue à
marseille alors et là on est en train
d'essayer de trouver une solution pour
que vous puissiez aller dormir ce soir
pour mme également fait le coach me
connaît mme cac l'oréal bartenheim king
charles k josh mans restera comme un
grand
pourquoi le système des familles
d'accueil n'est pas de développer ici
vous fait voir des gens pourraient être
sollicités dans l'urgence pour mettre à
l'abri des enfants amis concrètement là
la seule solution panda c'est de faire
appel à un collectif mais c'est aux gens
comment finalement laissé logique
institutionnelle finissent par faire
perdre aux fourneaux en tant que citoyen
mais pas nous pousser à dans les marges
la limite de la fraude dans des réseaux
un petit peu balton comptes axa
et après il faut vraiment qu'ils
allument un matin à 9h où ça amène à
donc là maintenant on attend la réponse
sa réponse d'anne hébergement le secret
secret
alors on va trouver quelqu'un qui peut
nous prendre à dormir chez lui ce soit
pour mega man 9 appareils chaque année
aux normes cherche ma femme
donc c'est tranquille pour ce soir vous
êtes au chaud
[Musique]
ok
ammann a misé maria hockey ouais comme
welcome flèche lunch
toile f1
all together pourquoi
et
ce
mais d'abord il a multiplié mardi n'y a
qu'un seul destin est riche et france et
netto be strong aussi pleine forme ok
bat for you you you you with more than
one tno
[Musique]
yab est fort de mouvement et will be
l'acdi pour le moment maybe we live play
n 11 bat soul and you will have played
after he is not possible to not possible
to god of child d'agrafage sixtine years
old
canadian luan your death and so you just
came to day and the boys are waiting to
haiti white et waiting alors je t'écoute
hockey ouais hammam et aux mythes à
super ok aujourd'hui super ok parfait
très bien merci by ce fut bon week-end
merci au revoir
super vous avez une place tous les deux
en foyer tous les deux foyers
yahoo tonight
yes bof servio brothers de ses bras
c'est super c'est vous avez beaucoup de
chance
le dow jones way you have got a lot of
church puisqu'au exceptionally monoplace
merci chez vous